اصحابه الستره البيضاء يطلون مره اخرى
باضراب واسع يشل حركه قطاع الصحه في
بريطانيا الاف الاطباء الشباب باشروا
اضرابا يمتدوا لاربعه ايام للمطالبه برفع
الاجور بنسبه مرتفعه تصل الى 35%
ويعد هذا ثاني اضراب كبير يهز الخدمه
الصحيه في بريطانيا في غضون اشهر بعد
اضراب الممرضين وموظفي القطاع نهايه العام
الماضي هذا وابدت الحكومه انزعاجها من هذا
الاضراب حيث وصف وزير الصحه ستيف باركلي
للاضطرابات بانها مخيبه للامال للغايه
وقال ان طلب الجمعيه الطبيه البريطانيه
غير معقول لانه سيؤدي الى حصول بعض
الاطباء المبتدئين على زياده في الاجور
تفوق 20 الف جنيه استرليني وكانت لهذا
الاضراب تبعات سلبيه على الرعايه الصحيه
في بريطانيا حيث ادى الى تاجيل 350 الف
موعد طبي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات